and finally new rule someone has to tell
me if we can do this now why can't we do
this people have started flying again
and some planes have been packed why is
American Airlines safe but not American
Airlines Arena viruses like concerts but
are afraid of flying then how about we
have a concert on a plane maybe Elton
John could lend us his old tour plane
the one with the organ on board would
would that make a concert safe and it if
it happened at 30,000 feet in a cabin
filled with recycled coughs and farts
while involuntarily spooning with the
guy in 32b look I'm glad the airlines
are back in business I'd like to see
everybody back in business and if folks
are willing to take precautions and
accept a small risk so life can go on I
say let that be our guide the White
House press corps is allowed to cover
Trump's briefings and of course they
should that's where we learn the
drinking motor oil cures aids but if
Donald Trump is allowed to do his comedy
act with an audience why can't I this
reopening has no consistency in LA you
still can't legally get a haircut but
you can get your dog's hair cut so he
doesn't look stupid in zoo meetings
museums are typically spacious and very
low-risk why are they close but you can
sweat and sway in a church we're not
supposed to congregate but that's
literally called a congregation Georgia
reopened massage parlors before
restaurants which only makes sense if
the massage parlor served waffles and
the Waffle House gives happy endings
across America parks are open again but
park restrooms are not so what move over
bears it's our turn to in the woods
it also seems like there's a different
set of rules for single people no one
bats an eye if you live with family
members who are coming and going but if
a mere friend who's not part of the
Emily steps inside the house break out
the hazmat suits here's an interesting
fact about viruses they don't recognize
marriage and sharing a mailing address
does not confer immunity and we're not
questioning any of this which is a
problem does anyone in charge of health
in this country have any idea how much
less healthy an airplane is than a
baseball game let me help you out
researchers studied 7,300 kovat cases in
China and found just one that was
connected to outdoor transmission yeah
you've heard people use the phrase
sunlight is the best disinfectant well
that got to be a metaphor because it was
true the virus doesn't like Sun like
rudy giuliani but humans do like sun and
need it there is a strong correlation
between vitamin D deficiency and
mortality rates science daily reports on
research that shows it might be as high
as cutting the mortality rate in half
well vitamin D is something you get from
the Sun not your phone screen outdoors
healthy unabomber lifestyle not healthy
why haven't our top health officials
been emphasizing these things
why haven't they given us any direction
on improving our immune systems at a
time when we need them the most
imagine before the virus even existed
telling your doctor hey doc I've been
locking myself indoors living in fear
day drinking and eating cheap takeout
good healthcare plan the vacuum and
leadership isn't Trump alone yes
he puts the cluster in yes
he is the worst leader the world has
seen since edia men stopped eating the
voters but in late January doctor foul
Qi said the corona virus was quote a
very very low risk to the United States
it isn't something the American public
needs to worry about or be frightened
about On January 23rd Trump got a
briefing from US intelligence and he
claims they under
played the danger then but the New York
Times points out that Trump ignored a
host of warnings he received around that
time from high-ranking government
officials epidemiologists scientists bio
defense officials other national
security aides
and the news media about the viruses
growing threat so all those people knew
it was a threat by then but doctor foul
she was saying very very low risk in in
March thought she told 60 minutes
there's no reason to be walking around
with a mask well there was and he is now
that month he also said if you want to
go on a cruise ship go on a cruise ship
look I think doctor foul he is honorable
smart and sincere but I also thought
that about Robert Muller and I worry
liberals are once again falling into the
same trap of lionizing someone just
because they're the anti-trump even
before the virus America had a far too
chronically sick population which is one
reason we've lost so many now we need to
demand something better than how the
entrenched medical establishment manages
symptoms but cures and heals far too
little
[Music]